Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass – was ist eigentlich in anderen europäischen Top-Ligen so los? Dieser Frage wollen wir im Kurzpass jetzt immer mal wieder nachgehen und wir beginnen mit einem Blick nach England auf die Premier League mit DAZN-Kommentator Uli Hebel. Uli, sei mir gegrüßt.
Grüß dich, ich bin zurück im Rasenfunk.
Ja, sehr schön, nachdem wir ja mal ein Tribüngespräch zusammen aufgezeichnet haben in extremen Bedingungen über deine Arbeit unter anderem ja bei DAZN. Jetzt ein Kurzpass. Schön, dass du wieder mit dabei bist.
Ich freue mich sehr und dann noch in meiner liebsten Thematik, das ist mir das Allerliebste.
Ja, sehr gut. Wir reden heute mal über die Premier League. Wir wollen so einen allgemeinen Überblick geben. Ich denke, diejenigen, die wöchentlich alle Spiele sehen, die werden jetzt viel Bekanntes hören, aber es richtet sich eher an die Hörerinnen und Hörer, die nicht immer die Zeit haben, jede Liga im Blick zu haben. Und da wollen wir jetzt mal im Kurzpass versuchen, ob wir hin und wieder mal auf andere Ligen blicken können. Ja, die Premier League, sie wird dominiert von einer Mannschaft, das wird jetzt, glaube ich, niemanden da draußen überraschen, nämlich Manchester City. Bei einem Spiel weniger 13 Punkte Vorsprung. Da soll noch einer sagen, die Bundesliga wäre langweilig. Sag mir mal Uli, was macht denn City so stark? Wer macht City so stark?
Also ich glaube, ein Name, mit dem das einhergeht, da erzähle ich jetzt auch nichts Großneues, ist tatsächlich Pep Guardiola, weil es unglaublich ist, was der über den Sommer erarbeitet hat. Also natürlich ist Manchester City jetzt nicht erst seit dem Sommer erarbeitet worden, sondern auch in der Saison vorher, aber über den Sommer haben die einen riesengroßen Sprung gemacht, sicherlich auch viel Geld investiert, um diesen Sprung machen zu können, sich das Personal entsprechend dazu zu holen, aber das dann so zu formen, dass die so vorne weg marschieren gegen eine Konkurrenz, die stark ist, die eine gute Saison spielt, das ist schon ganz großartig. Da geht ganz, ganz viel auf das Konto von Pep Guardiola, der das, was er bei Bayern München schon gemacht hat, adaptiert hat, auf die Insel und das Ganze mit sehr, sehr atletischen Spielern, ich will fast sagen, noch ein Stück weiter getrieben hat. Das ist ganz schwierig. Vielleicht hat er das auch nur verändert, aber ich glaube, dass er sogar noch einen Ticken besser gemacht hat als damals bei den Bayern.
Aber es ist weiter das Guardiola-typische Spiel, viel Ballbesitz, viele Kurzpässe und dann bewegt man sich so, legt man sich den Gegner so zurecht, dass man dann irgendwann durchstecken kann und auf einmal gibt es die große Chance und man erzieht den Treffer oder hat sich da was verändert?
Zu 80-85% würde ich sagen, ist es dieses Spiel. Es ist ein bisschen variabler geworden, ein bisschen darauf ausgelegt, dass viele Gegner eher etwas defensiver kommen noch und sehr robust defensiv kommen, gerade aus den unteren Tabellenhälften, sodass da mehr Variabilität noch eingebaut worden ist. Ich will sagen, es darf auch gerne mal, das ist glaube ich inzwischen auch tatsächlich Stilmittel, der lange Ball von hinten rauskommen vom Verteidiger, der dann die beiden Seiten bespielt jeweils oder aber und vor allen Dingen die Läufe von den beiden Außen zwischen die Linien rein in die Schnittstelle des Innenverteidigers zum Außenverteidiger. Das macht dann typischerweise Raheem Sterling vor allen Dingen von der rechten Seite oder Lyrious Hane. Da ist dann auch noch mal mehr das 1 gegen 1 forciert, als das bei den Bayern der Fall gewesen ist, weil die beiden einfach dieser Disziplin unglaublich stark sind. Aber im Grunde genommen kann man das schon vergleichen. Sogar Diola hat seinen Stil jetzt nicht komplett verändert, angepasst würde ich sagen, an die Englische Liga.
Ja, echt faszinierend, wie ihr das jetzt schon zum dritten Mal hinbekommt, sich eben ja so eine Dominanz zu arbeiten in einer Liga. Du bist ja schon ein langjähriger Beobachter der Premier League. Würdest du sagen, das hat es in der Form schon mal gegeben? Oder ist das etwas Neues jetzt auch für den englischen Fußball?
Na, wir haben schon immer mal wieder über die Jahre gesehen, dass da eine Welle, eine taktische Art und Weise zu arbeiten, so ein bisschen das Land erobert hat. Wir müssen mal sehen, von welcher Nachhaltigkeit das Ganze ist, weil wir auch das schon erlebt haben. Also, bestes Beispiel ist jetzt der FC Chelsea, der letztes Jahr mit der Fünferkette alles revolutioniert hat. Und das interessiert schon gar keinen mehr, weil die einfach so weit ab vom Schuss sind. Die machen sich auch ein bisschen selber kaputt. Das liegt daran. Aber natürlich, wir haben immer mal wieder Einflüsse gesehen von anderen Ligen. Die Premier League ist da sehr offen. Was heißt offen? Die sind fast schon manisch, dass sie andere Einflüsse brauchen, um ihr Spiel selbst zu befruchten. Das heißt, ausländische Trainer zu holen, ausländische Mentalitäten, Philosophien dann mit rein zu bringen. Aber so in dieser Form, in diesem Überfall fast, den Manchester City veranstaltet auf die Liga, kann ich mich tatsächlich nicht erinnern, die letzten Jahre, dass wir das so gesehen hätten. Weil die portugiesische Philosophie, wenn du so willst, von Mourinho, ist dem englischen Spiel näher. Die italienische Philosophie ist dem englischen Spiel etwas näher. Ja, Jürgen Klopp könnte man vielleicht noch nennen. Diese Gegenpressing-Offensive, das hat die auch ein bisschen überrascht. Das war so in dieser Intensität vielleicht nicht ganz klar. Aber diese Vollkommenheit des Neuen, die bei City da ist, sowohl gegen den Ball als auch mit dem Ball, das ist schon das Neueste. Und da merkst du auch, wie sich die Mannschaften überhaupt nicht darauf einstellen konnten.
Wer sind so die entscheidenden Spieler bei City? Mach mal ein bisschen Name-Dropping.
Kevin de Bruyne, drei Ausrufenzeichen. Das ist fantastisch, was der für eine Saison hinlegt. Es ist nicht zu fassen. Also sowohl in Vorlagen als auch in Vorlagen zu Vorlage. Das ist völlig irre, welche Zahlen der Typ auflegt. Also ich nenne sie mal, hat 19 Vorlagen in 40 Pflichtspielen geschafft und eine Dunkelziffer an Passen vor dem Pass.
Wahnsinn.
Also das, dass der gut war, das wissen alle, das wussten alle bei Manchester City, das wussten alle beim VfL Wolfsburg, das wussten auch alle vorher schon beim FC Chelsea oder in Genk, wo er gespielt hat in Belgien. Aber der hat nochmal so einen großen Schritt gemacht. Der lacht dauernd, also er lacht selbst nicht, aber innerlich lacht er dauernd, weil er jetzt endlich unter Guardiola spielen darf, weil er ein Korsett um sich herum hat, um sich selbst frei bewegen zu können, weil er neben sich Leute hat wie David Silver. Das ist ein Match made in heaven, sagt der Engländer. Die beiden haben sich gefunden und die Herzen sich andauernd gegenseitig auf den Platz mitpessen, weil beide eigentlich jetzt nicht sehr emotional sich verausgaben. Es ist unglaublich, welches Raumgefühl der hat, welches Passgefühl der hat, wie unglaublich der auch einen Willen entwickelt hat, den man an ihm selbst gar nicht so festmachen kann, wenn du ihn so siehst, wenn du ihn so rumlaufen siehst. Aber du merkst es einfach. Es gab kurz vor Weihnachten eine Partie, wo er mit Verdacht auf Kreuzbandriss mindestens runter musste und alle gedacht haben, jetzt ist er für Monate raus und im nächsten Spiel steht er auf dem Platz. Und Guardiola hat hinterher nur gesagt, ich konnte ihn nicht bremsen. Er wollte spielen. Und das ist A-Sinnbild für Manchester City und B-Sinnbild für Kevin de Bruyne. Der hat einfach nur großen, großen Spaß am Fußballspielen. Derzeit unter Guardiola insbesondere. Und das macht ihn wirklich stark. Also das ist nochmal unter den vielen, vielen individuellen Könnern, die City diese Saison hat, ist das nochmal die Ausnahme.
Ja, und auch ohne die dunkelziffer Wahnsinnigezahlen. Du hast die 19 Vorlagen schon genannt in 40 Pflichtspielen. Dazu kommen ja noch 11 Tore. Das heißt, 30 Torbeteiligung in 40 Spielen. Unfassbar, da überragen ihn auch bei den erzieheten Toren gar nicht so viele. Ja, und auch bei Raheem Sterling 20 Tore in 36 Pflichtspielen und Sergio Aguero mit 30 Toren in 35 Pflichtspielen auch eine wahnsinnige Quote.
Ja, das ist auch so eine Geschichte dieser Aguero, der eigentlich dem Vernehmen nach nicht unbedingt geliebt ist von Guardiola und das beruht dann, glaube ich, auch auf Gegenseitigkeit. Aber Jesus hat sich verletzt in demselben Spiel im Übrigen, das ich gerade zitiert hatte bei de Bruyne, hat er sich verletzt, war mit einem Innenbandriss jetzt knapp drei Monate raus und dann war Aguero plötzlich wieder der erste Name auf der Aufstellung und trifft und trifft und trifft und trifft und das ist das Erstaunliche bei dem. Der ist 29 Jahre alt. Ich finde, so von der Reputation her hat er es nie so in die ganz finale Weltklasse geschafft. Also wenn wir Mittelstürmer nennen müssten, dann würden wir wahrscheinlich drei bis vier andere Namen nennen. Da kommen dann plötzlich auch so Namen wie Romedo Lukaku, der nicht im Ansatz in der Liga agiert, auf Jahre hinweg, wie das Aguero tut. Der trifft andauernd, hat jetzt 199 Tore im Trikot der Sky Blues gemacht. Das 200. ist eine Frage der Zeit. Ich würde mal behaupten, Donnerstag ist es soweit. Wieder gegen Arsenal und ja, unglaublich. Und Sterling, den du genannt hast, auch das, da manifestiert sich ganz gut, was Guardiola tut. Er hat viele gute Spieler, die waren auch vorher schon im Kader von Manchester City, aber er hat vielen guten Spielern einfach einen Plan gegeben. Und ich habe das Gefühl, er versorgt sie mit ganz viel Selbstvertrauen, sodass die einfach die Dinge machen, zu denen sie rein theoretisch im Stande sind. Dass Raheem Sterling das Material hat, um Defensiven zu zerstören, das ist uns allen klar, wenn wir den sehen. Also der ist sehr schnell, der ist sehr trickreich, der ist total inspiriert am Ball auch. Hat das aber nie, geschweige denn über 90 Minuten, aber auch kaum mal 10, 15 Minuten am Stück gezeigt. Und seit Guardiola da ist, ist der eine ständige Bedrohung für die Hintermannschaft. Immer wieder der Lauf, immer wieder der Lauf. Wenn er nicht funktioniert, dann ist er dritte und beim vierten Mal klappt es dann plus den Abschluss, den er ihm irgendwie draufgepackt haben muss. Also der wird in den Körper gesteckt haben, aber das muss ja eine psychologische Komponente haben. Das ist unglaublich. Also er hat jeden Spieler – das ist eine platte Formulierung – aber er hat jeden Spieler viel, viel besser gemacht in jetzt nicht ganz eineinhalb Jahren.
Wahnsinn. Ist es nicht schön, dass man auch bei diesem Spruch immer an Jürgen Klinsmann denken muss, ich mag das irgendwie. Jetzt haben wir viel über Offensivspieler gesprochen. Bevor wir noch über andere Vereine auch reden wollen, hätte ich noch eine andere Frage. Also City hat ja auch sehr, sehr viel investiert. Also allein die Zugänge 2016, 2017 haben 213 Millionen Euro gekostet. In der aktuellen Transferperiode sind wir schon bei 315 Millionen Euro. Unglaublicher Kapitaleinsatz. Und es sind auch sehr, sehr viele Defensivspieler gekommen. Was kann man denn über die Defensive von City sagen? Die geht ja fast ein bisschen unter bei dieser Lobrudelei. Aber nur 20 kassierte Tore ist ja auch beste Abwehr der Liga zusammen mit United.
Ja, ganz genau. Und vor allen Dingen wieder ist geschafft, das Ganze im Verbund zu formieren. Das heißt, die Einzelspieler in der Defensive sind gar nicht mal so herausragend. Die hatten da auch viele Verletzungsprobleme, insbesondere in der Innenverteidigung. Uttar Mendy ist jemand, der auffällt, weil er ebenfalls einen riesen Spuren gemacht hat über den Sommer und vorher recht leichtfüßig oft unterwegs war, viele, viele Konzentrationsschwächen hatte und eigentlich auch vom Paket her, wenn du dir den Körper ansiehst, der ist relativ klein, der wirkt nicht besonders athletisch, der war nie ein guter Kopfballspieler, der hat nie durch Intelligenz geglänzt und all das plötzlich da. Ganz verrückt ist es plötzlich alles da bei dem, es ist der Abwehrchef und dann eben die von dir angesprochenen Zugänge, zumeist auf der rechten Seite Kyle Walker, der zwischenzeitlich teuerste Verteidiger der Welt, der einfach eine gewisse Athletik dazu addiert. Jetzt aber gar nicht so unbedingt überragend auffällt, Mandy ist verletzt, das heißt, sie ist gar nicht so zum Einsatz gekommen bislang. Stattdessen wurde mit Fabian Derff, ein eigentlich schon ausrangierter zentral defensiver Mittelfelder, zum Linksverteidiger umfunktioniert. Und der funktioniert dann auch plötzlich in diesem Kollektiv. Also ich glaube, da ist die große Stärke, Citys zu suchen und zu finden, neben dem Torhüter Ederson, der einen Riesenjob macht. Aber da ist die Stärke zu finden, dass das alles im Kollektiv wahnsinnig kompakt, im Informationsflug immer und dauernd funktioniert. Und da hast du dann halt gut genüge Individualisten, um das Ganze dann einfach komplett zu kaschieren. Das ist glaube ich einfach aber auch immer schon bei allen Mannschaften das System Guardiola gewesen, dass du in der Defensive Spezialisten hast, die zusammen dann dir den Verbund schaffen.
Und dann kommen eben 13 Punkte Vorsprung bei einem Spiel weniger heraus. Vor dem zweiten Manchester United, dahinter dann der FC Liverpool und Tottenham Hotspur, das sind aktuell die ersten vier der Liga. Erklär mir mal kurz, was fehlt denn bei den Verfolgern, was City gerade hat? Lass mal mit Manchester United beginnen, denn die sind die einzigen, die eigentlich immer unter den ersten zwei Plätzen waren. Einmal an einem Spieltag waren sie Tabellen dritter, aber ansonsten immer erster ganz am Anfang der Saison und jetzt der Dauerzweite im Grunde.
Also eins vorneweg, all diese genannten Mannschaften, die spielen eigentlich eine starke Saison. Wäre Manchester City nicht so völlig über den Dingen derzeit, dann würden wir sowohl Manchester United den nächsten Schritt attestieren, als auch Liverpool, als auch den Spurs, die dann alle irgendwo beieinander um die Meisterschaft kämpfen. Ihnen fehlt nicht viel, die spielen alle eine gute Saison, die haben alle recht wenige Niederlagen, haben relativ viele Siege, Liverpool mehr unentschieden, aber auch viele Siege und eine wahnsinns offensive. Das liegt im Moment an Manchester City, dass die so weit oben drüber drohen, dass wir denen nicht das Lob zusprechen können, dass sie eigentlich verdienen, weil alle für sich noch mal einen Schritt weitergegangen sind.
Sehr faszinierend. Was hat denn dann sich bei United vor allem verändert im Vergleich zur letzten Saison?
Ich glaube, dass die Spieler mehr und mehr verstehen, was Mourinho von ihnen möchte. Und wir wissen alle, dass er nicht der Samstagabend-Entertainer ist, Mourinho. Also vor allen Dingen als Trainer, wie er spielen lässt. Das müssen sie auch gar nicht. Aber sie holen die Ergebnisse noch mehr, als sie das vergangene Saison schon getan haben. Da war es schon ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung, dass sie Spiele, die sie vielleicht kurz davor waren zu verlieren, zumindest unentschieden gespielt haben. Und in dieser Saison gewinnen sie recht häufig. Es fehlt noch, dass sie tatsächlich auch die kleinen Gegner dann mal schlagen. Da leisten sie sich zu viele Punktverluste. Aber nochmal, sie sind auf einem sehr guten Weg. Sie sind vom Personal her in einer Altersstruktur, wo ich denke, dass ihnen alles Gute noch bevorsteht. In der Theorie. Man addiert dann immer mal wieder einen für mich zu alten Spieler dazu. Aber im Grunde genommen sind sie auf dem richtigen Weg. Sie entwickeln sich normal, wohingegen Manchester City sich einfach mit Fast Forward entwickelt hat, jetzt im Sommer.
Ja, das ist schon Wahnsinn. Das ist auch eine richtige Einordnung von dir. Wenn wir hier über einen Tabellen-Zweit mit fünf Niederlagen sprechen, dann ist es ja immer noch nicht viel. Und wie ich vorhin schon erwähnt habe, die beste Verteidigung zusammen mit City. United auch nur 20 Tore kassiert. Ist der Spielstil von Mourinho noch so, wie man ihn aus vielen Champions-League-Spielzeiten Erinnerungen hat? Das heißt, ich würde ihn mal als pragmatisch bezeichnen.
Ja, in den meisten Fällen ist das so. Ich glaube, die Manchester United-Fans nennen das dann gemeinhin langweilig. Ja, es ist schon im Wesentlichen noch so. Es gibt Tage, wo dann einfach die Zauberer auf dem Platz, die ohne Zweifel vorhanden sind, ob er, wenn er will, gut drauf ist, Martha, wenn er will und gut drauf ist und wenn er gesund war oder ist, mit dabei ist Ibrahimovic, wo die dann plötzlich schon auch anfangen, nach dem ersten Tor sich selbst so ein bisschen zu entfesseln und wirklich Spaß am Fußball zu haben. Aber im Grunde genommen ist nach wie vor Safety First bei Manchester United und ich glaube, es gibt auch gar keinen Grund, da großartig davon abzurücken. Denn die United-Fans, die jetzt über Langeweile klagen, die sollen sich mal zurückerinnern, was in den erfolgreichsten Jahren unter Sir Alex Ferguson gegeben war, nämlich nichts anderes. Das waren in aller Regel – also ich erinnere mich da häufig dran – Samstag 16 Uhr, das waren dreckige 1-0-Siege gegen Crystal Palace, gegen Southampton und Coventry und wie sie alle hießen. Also nochmal, die sind komplett auf dem richtigen Weg, glaube ich. Die eine oder andere Entscheidung würde ich mir eher pro jungen Spielern wünschen, also pro Martial, pro Rashford, dass diese Leute sich entwickeln dürfen, weil ich der Meinung bin, dass Manchester United nichts zukaufen muss im Sommer. Die haben alle Lösungen im eigenen Kader und die müssen jetzt einfach nur ruhig bleiben und dürfen sich – und das ist ganz schwierig natürlich, wenn der in Anführungszeichen kleine Nachbar Manchester City so über dir thront – aber die dürfen sich daran gar nicht orientieren, sondern einfach weitermachen. Vielleicht gibt es ja auch im Europapokal die Möglichkeit, dann was zu holen. Mourinho ist da ja durchaus spezialisiert drauf und dann ist nämlich der kleine Nachbar Manchester City plötzlich auch gar nicht mehr so laut.
Ja, da steht uns eh noch einiges bevor im Europapokal mit den englischen Mannschaften, glaube ich. Da hat jetzt United auswärts in Sevilla ein Mourinho-typisches 0 zu 0 geholt und es war auch nicht viel mehr als das, was man wollte. So hatte man zumindest den Eindruck, wenn man das Spiel gesehen hat. Auf den FC Liverpool liegt ja so ein bisschen immer das Augenmerk der deutschen Betrachter – logischerweise wegen Jürgen Klopp. Wie ist denn da die Entwicklung?
Also prinzipiell finde ich die recht positiv. Wenn wir aber ins Detail gehen, dann hat Liverpool eigentlich immer noch dieselben Probleme wie die vergangenen Spielzeiten. Nämlich, dass der Schnitt zwischen Offensive und Defensive noch immer nicht so ganz gut. Es gibt Spiele, wo Liverpool das sehr ordentlich gemacht hat. Es gibt aber auch Spiele, wo sie nach wie vor zu viele Tore kassieren. Und mir fehlt nach wie vor noch so der Schritt, der mich glauben lässt, dass sie ganz nah dran sind.
Ja, hat das mit Personal zu tun oder hat das vielleicht auch mit Adaption der Taktik zu tun?
Ich glaube in allererster Linie das Zweite, dass die Taktik teilweise recht ausrechenbar ist auf dem ganz ganz hohen Niveau. Sie haben Riesenspiele gemacht wie gegen Manchester City, wo du dann aber auch siehst, sie sind 4 zu 1 vorne und dann steht es am Ende 4 zu 3 und die letzte Aktion hätte beinahe noch den Ausgleich gebracht. Das heißt, sie wenden wahnsinnig viel auf, das funktioniert auch über 60, 70 Minuten gut, es wird auch immer mehr. Also in der Entwicklung Klopp muss man tatsächlich konstatieren, es wird besser, es werden mehrere Minuten, sie sind insgesamt konstanter.
Die haben ja auch nur drei Niederlagen, das ist ja eigentlich wahnsinnig wenig.
Genau, und legen immer mal wieder ganz, ganz gute Läufe hin. Aber die Problematik ist, dass sie hinten raus dann immer mal wieder einbrechen oder einzelne Spiele haben, wo sie sich dann die Ausgangslage eben so ein bisschen selbst fast verhunzen. Also die gewinnen gegen Manchester City, erste Niederlage-Cities in der Saison und im Montagspiel darauf gegen die Tabellen letztens, wollen sie die zu dem Zeitpunkt aber überhaupt nichts damit zu tun hatten, was Liverpool auf den Platz bringt, verlieren sie dann, weil sie wieder mit dem Ball vor einer tief verschränkten Abwehr nichts anzufangen wissen, weil sie plötzlich diese Tempoläufe nicht reinbekommen, weil sie plötzlich den Ball nicht so zirkulieren lassen können, wie man sich das vorstellt. Also das ist eine schwierige Sache mit Liverpool. Ich glaube, die stehen im Moment entweder da, wo sie hingehören, vielleicht sogar noch plus ein oder zwei Plätze da, wo sie eigentlich hingehören. Gute Entwicklung, mir eine zu langsame Entwicklung, aber vielleicht muss man da auch noch ein bisschen abwarten.
Und deckt sich deine Meinung da auch mit der Stimmung im Umfeld? Wie ist denn gerade so? Liverpool hat ja auch nochmal ein besonderes Umfeld, würde ich sagen, unter Premier League-Vereinen.
Ja, also diese Siege wie gegen Manchester City, wo du mal das volle Potenzial ausgeschöpft siehst dieser Mannschaft, die sorgen natürlich dafür, dass die Erwartungshaltung ein bisschen steigt. Und Jürgen Klopp ist jetzt in seiner, wenn ich nicht lüge, dritten vollständigen Spielzeit bei Liverpool. Und er hat jetzt auch Geld ausgegeben, also dieser Van Dijk-Transfer. Das ist ein Statement, auch wenn man dann Coutinho natürlich wieder abgegeben hat. Aber der Engländer macht sich in diesem Punkt sehr gerne sehr einfach und sagt, wir haben ausgegeben. Es wird im Sommer erwartet, dass noch mehr ausgegeben wird. Dir wird aber mit Can wieder ein, ja, können wir ruhig sagen, Schlüsselspieler-Wohlabhanden kommen. Und dann musst du da wieder neu drum aufbauen. Ach, das ist eine, glaube ich, persönliche Geschichte von Emre Can, der A gerne reist und B wohl, das ist so das, was man so aus dem Umfeld hört, lieber offensiver spielen würde, gerne bei Liverpool als auf dieser defensiven Rolle. Klopp kann ihn das aber nicht garantieren, weil da einfach andere Leute gesetzt sind oder waren vor allen Dingen, als Coutinho noch da war. Dementsprechend denke ich, dass das eher da zu verorten ist. Und Klopp hat das auch im Interview bei The Zone bestätigt, dass Can jemand ist, der auch ganz gerne sich alle zwei, drei Jahre wohl verändert. Da habe ich schon gemeint durchzuhören, dass er irgendwie die Entscheidung schon kennt. Das war vor, glaube ich, zwei, drei Wochen so was.
Ja, stimmt, habe ich auch gesehen. So habe ich es auch interpretiert.
Also, ich denke, da ist man sich schon relativ einig darüber. Aber wie gesagt, also Geld ausgegeben, Statement gemacht. Und die Gruppe, die Fanway Sports Group, die da das sagen hat in Liverpool, die wollen und die müssen auch Titel einfordern. Denn die anderen geben auch zwar Geld aus, aber die sind schon wieder… Also City hat sie jetzt plötzlich überholt. Manchester United hat sie plötzlich überholt. Liverpool war eigentlich schon ein zweiter in der Entwicklung als diese beiden Mannschaften. Und die stehen jetzt aber deutlich wieder drüber. Andersrum gesagt, Klopp muss irgendwann Titel holen. Wie auch immer geartet, er muss irgendwann Titel holen, denn ansonsten wird er einfach nur als Charismatiker irgendwann abgestempelt und dann wird Liverpool sich auf kurz oder lang was anderes überlegen. Das ist die unromantische Version. Die romantischere Version wäre, man lässt ihn einfach mal arbeiten. Ich erinnere aber nochmal an das Beispiel. Selbe Führungsebene, Brandon Rogers, der Platz 2 geholt hat in der Premier League seiner Zeit, eine riesen, riesen, riesen Saison gespielt hat. Dann sind die Suarez-Apannten gekommen, dann wurde Sturridge, ist leider nicht mehr so gut gewesen. So, und dann hast du die Erwartungshaltung geschaffen. Die anderen sind an ihnen vorbeigezogen. Und irgendwann ist es dann aus. Obwohl die Statistiken, rein die Statistiken insgesamt, Brandon Rogers, bis zu dieser Saison die Besseren waren als die von Jürgen Klopp. Auch jemand, glaube ich, sehr vergleichbar, der den Verein charismatisch mitgezogen hat, der eine ganz eigene Philosophie an den Tag hat legen lassen, also Liverpool wieder so ein ganz eigenes Gefühl eingeschärft hat. Aber das ist dann irgendwann unterm Strich alles nichts mehr wert, wenn du den Titel nicht holst. Den braucht Liverpool endlich.
Wahnsinn, das war doch die Saison, der Stevie G dann ausgerutscht ist, als man tatsächlich ein Führer war und ach Gott, das war fürchterlich anzusehen, wenn man es mit dem FC Liverpool hier zu diesem Zeitpunkt gut. Der Champions League sieht sehr positiv aus, auswärts beim FC Porto 5 zu Null gewonnen. Ich denke, da kann man mit dem Viertelfinale planen und vielleicht ist ja das dann der Wettbewerb, in dem Jürgen Klopp so ein bisschen Meriten sammeln kann. Was kannst du mir denn über die Spurs erzählen, die auf Platz 4 liegen und das ist alles recht eng beieinander. Also wir sprechen hier über Teams United, Liverpool, Spurs, die liegen innerhalb von vier Punkten. Da könnte sich noch einiges drehen.
Ja, also bei den Spurs ist es so, dass sie leider immer mal wieder sich eine Dürrephase gönnen und deshalb nicht ganz oben ran reichen. Leider sage ich aus dem Grund, weil ich das so im Kaderbau, das aufregendste Team der ganzen Liga finde. Unglaublich jung, alle in einer recht ähnlichen Altersklasse, in einer recht ähnlichen Altersstruktur. Du hast mit Mauricio Pochettino einen Trainer, der genau weiß, was er will, der genau auch so die Spieler dazu addiert, der wirklich athletische, schussstarke, sehr variable Spieler haben. Ich gehe fast zu weit und sage, das ist fast der positionslose Fußball, der irgendwann mal so in zwei, drei Jahren, glaube ich, noch mehr den Kontinent einnehmen wird. Da dürfen wir uns schon mal dran gewöhnen.
Geil.
Ja, also sehr interessant, was der da vor allen Dingen machen lässt. Er hat ein paar Arbeiter mit drin, die einfach die Dinge so vorbereiten für die, die dann glänzen. Die kennen wir dann alle, die Namen. Harry Kane, Dally Alley, Christian Eriksen. Also sehr interessante Mannschaft, die sich nach wie vor entwickeln, die aber so ein bisschen aufpassen müssen, dass ihnen da eben die anderen auch nicht enteilen. Denn ansonsten ist dieses Projekt ja leider fast nicht richtig ausgenutzt. Ich will sagen, auch da irgendwann müssen halt Titel folgen. Die sind jetzt so seit 3, 4 Jahren beieinander, sind noch alle wahnsinnig jung. Ali ist 21, Harry Kane ist, auch wenn man das fast gar nicht glauben kann, erst 24 Jahre alt. Der einzige, der so ein bisschen rauswachsen wird irgendwann, ist Musa Dembele, der auch völlig unterm Radar ist. Völlig zu unrecht, weil er einer der ganz großen Mittelfeldspieler in dieser Liga ist. Er hat fast geniale Züge an sich, was Ballverteilung betrifft, also so kreative Visionen auf dem Feld. Für mich ist das interessanteste Team, wo ich noch nicht so ganz hundertprozentig absehen kann, wo geht es hin, aber wo ich immer einen besonderen Blick darauf habe, einfach weil die an guten Tagen ein so aufregendes Fußballspiel liefern können, die Spurs. Ein bisschen mehr Konsistenz muss rein und dann kann das auch weit gehen mit ihnen.
Aber schon interessant, dass du jetzt bei allen Verfolgern gesagt hast, vor allem bei Liverpool und den Spurs, da muss jetzt mal ein Titel her. Das kann man ja auch sehr gut nachvollziehen. Andererseits bewegt man sich aber halt auch in einer unglaublich starken Liga. Und dann hast du jetzt so einen Dominator wie City und dann ist es natürlich auch schwierig, etwas Nachhaltiges aufzubauen, wenn du immer sagst, im dritten oder im vierten Jahr des Trainers, spätestens, wenn jetzt nicht langsam der Titel kommt, dann machen wir den Rogers-Abgang, den du vorhin schon zitiert hast, bei Liverpool, der ungewollte Abgang. Ist das nicht auch langfristig ein Problem für die Liga? Ich meine, über das Gegenbeispiel FC Arsenal sprechen wir gleich noch, aber irgendwie doch auch ein bisschen paradox.
Ja, ja, natürlich. Das ist das große Problem. Wir alle müssen wissen, die spielen, um Titel zu holen und die werden auch letztendlich daran gemessen, weil die Payrolls entsprechend aufgepumpt sind inzwischen. Auf der Insel, überall, aber insbesondere auf der Insel. Ja, das ist ein großes Problem. Ich glaube, bei den anderen beiden genannten Manchester United und Liverpool ist es ein bisschen anders geartet. Die haben einfach aus dem Selbstverständnis raus diesen unbedingtem Titel Hunger, fast schon die Pflicht bei Manchester United, was zu holen. Bei den Spurs ist es eher so, dass die traditionellen Teams sind, die zwei Jahre lang gut performen haben und dann plötzlich Leistungsträger verloren haben, Trainer verloren haben. Und das steht bevor. Und deswegen habe ich da so ein bisschen Torschusspanik, was die Spurs angeht, weil ich das Gefühl habe, wenn die nicht liefern, wenn die nicht innerhalb der nächsten eineinhalb Jahre Silber holen, dann überlegt sich ein Daley Alley anders. Dann überlegt sich Pep Guardiola, ob er nicht Daley Alley holen soll, weil er gut reinpassen würde. Dann überlegt sich Manchester United, ob die nicht Daley Alley holen sollen. Was macht Harry Kane dann tatsächlich, wenn der merkt mit 5, 6 und 20, ich schieße zwar Jahr für Jahr die Liga kaputt, aber wir holen hier nichts.
Ja, genau. Und mit Silber holen meinst du ja quasi Gold holen, weil die Caps alle aus Silber sind.
Sorry, ich denke zu eng. Ja, und vor allen Dingen der Trainer Mauricio Pochettino. Also wenn es bei Real Madrid Vakanzen gibt, dann ist inzwischen ein offenes Geheimnis, dass die die Telefonnummer Mauricio Pochettinos haben. Und ist der vielleicht verantwortlich dafür, was bei den Spurs jetzt in drei Jahren passiert ist? Kann das jemand anderes überhaupt fortführen? Oder passiert dann das, was bei Tottenham oft der Fall gewesen ist? Nämlich Schnitt und dann fängt jemand anders mit einer ganz anderen Idee nochmal an und dann holst du wieder nichts, dann gewinnst du erstmal nichts und dann gehen dir die ganzen Schlüsselspieler der Rheinach wieder weg. Das ist bei denen so ein bisschen geartet. Das ist so deren ganz eigene Depressionsgeschichte in den letzten Jahren insbesondere. Aber ja, du hast natürlich vollkommen recht, das macht es schwierig, dass du manchmal Entwicklungen, die eigentlich gut sind, abhängig machst oder in den Kontext des Titelgewinnens stellst und einfach vergisst, dass da gerade eine Mannschaft ist, die finanziell auf einem anderen Level operiert, die sportlich auf einem anderen Level operiert und die vor allen Dingen einfach gerade das Fenster offen hat, dass alles passt und du plötzlich losmarschieren kannst. Schwierig, das ist fast Philosophie.
Ja, so ein bisschen auch Wirtschaft und Ökonomie finde ich. Denn die Frage finde ich auch gar nicht so illegitim. Muss man denn wirklich Titel gewinnen, um Geld zu verdienen? Ich glaube, als Premier League-Verein gerade nicht mehr, da reicht es eigentlich schon, Teil der Premier League zu sein und an diesen wahnsinnigen TV-Geldern zu partizipieren. Aber es geht ja noch um was anderes, wenn wir über Titel sprechen. Die Spurs bei Juve zurückgekommen und ein 2 zu 2 erzielt. Das war auch ein sehr interessantes Spiel aus allen Richtungen. Also das war sehr schön anzuschauen. Dürfen wir gespannt sein aufs Rückspiel. Und jetzt lassen wir noch über Platz 5 und Platz 6 sprechen. Der FC Chelsea und der FC Arsenal. Chelsea ja als Meister in die Saison gegangen, aber das hat man ja schon bis nach Deutschland mitbekommen. Da lief es alles andere als rund.
Das ist ganz schlimm, was da mal wieder nach einer Meistersaison passiert. Nach Mourinho in der Folge-Saison wurde der dann irgendwann so im November rum entlassen. Zuletzt dann auch bei Ancelotti. Mal wieder im Selbstzerstörungsmodus. Sportlich hat sich nicht viel verändert. Das ist im Grunde genommen eine ähnliche Mannschaft, wenn auch ein bisschen ausgedünnt der Kader, was ich nie ganz verstanden habe, dass die da eine sehr eigene Transferpolitik an den Tag legen, nämlich wenig Zugänge haben, aber Schlüsselspieler wie beispielsweise Matic abgeben, ohne sich wirklich Ersatz zu organisieren. Und vor allen Dingen, und ich glaube darin ist, ja nennen wir es Krise, ich glaube das ist eine Krise aus der Sicht Chersies selbst auch. Da ist so ein bisschen die Antwort zu suchen, dass die Protagonisten wahnsinnig unglücklich kommunizieren konnten. Selbst der immer wieder öffentlich auch anmerkt, dass er mit Transferentscheidungen nicht viel zu tun hat, der öffentlich Liebe einfordert vom Vorstand, von Fans auch, die sie ihm auch geben, der sich immer wieder selbst auch in eine Position bringt, wo er sich beklagt über den Kaderbau, wo er sich beklagt über auch die ganze Spielsystematik in England, also den ganzen Terminplan. Also eigentlich nur am Lamentieren ist die ganze Zeit. So ein bisschen das verloren hat, was ihn ausgemacht hat in der vergangenen Saison, nämlich dass er sehr positiv vorwegging und fast schon Leichtigkeit transportiert hat. Das ist natürlich auch viel leichter, wenn du auf Platz 1 stehst, als wenn du auf Platz zwischenzeitlich 3, 4, 5. Da ist es ja schon runtergegangen aktuell. Und dann hast du auf der gegenüberliegenden Seite das Board. Da riecht es viel mehr, als wir das hier in Deutschland wahrnehmen. Der langjährige technische Direktor, der auch für die Entlassung Morinius vor drei Jahren, glaube ich, war es verantwortlich war, im Inalu musste gehen, hat einen internen Machtkampf verloren, mit der Frau, die seit neuestem auf jedem Bild zu sehen ist, in Transfers etc. Marina Granovskaia, die wiederum eine Enge vertraute. In Anführungszeichen, ich möchte jetzt nicht in dem Boulevard abtauchen, damit, glaube ich, weiß schon jeder, was gemeint ist, wo man Abramowitsch sein soll und deswegen sehr, sehr viel Macht bekommt. Und die wiederum hat überhaupt keine Lust auf Contest-Alleingänge und vor allen Dingen auf Contest-Verhalten, dass er sich so ein bisschen als den Vater des Erfolges der Meistersaison bei Jersey sieht. Ne, im Gegenteil, die macht ihr eigenes Ding. Die entscheidet, wer gekauft wird, die entscheidet, wer verkauft wird oder nicht verkauft wird. Spicebill Badgeroy zeigt es, glaube ich, ganz gut. Der Verein FC Chelsea will den zurückhaben, Conte denkt ja gar nicht daran, den überhaupt noch Minuten zu geben. Und da ging es auch schon los. Die haben einfach Matic verkauft, die haben teilweise ignoriert, was Conte gefordert hat als Ersatz. Und es wird immer so ein bisschen gestreut auch vom Board Chelsies, dass zum Beispiel das Training langweilig sei unter Conte. Also wir sagen, wahnsinnig viele Kommunikationsstränge. Das Problem ist, Conte und Granos Kaja kommunizieren nicht. Und das war immer das größte Problem. Das waren die größten Dämonen bei Chelsea in den vergangenen Jahren. Und wann immer das so war, wann immer wir diesen Befund so nehmen konnten, gab es richtig donner Wetter und es hat nicht gut geendet.
Ohje. Und wie wird es enden beim FC Arsenal, der ja schon mit einer deutlichen Lücke zum FC Chelsea auf Platz 6 aktuell liegt. Das sind schon 8 Punkte. Man hat allerdings auch 8 Punkte Vorsprung dann auf Platz 7. Das heißt, ich würde den Tabell in Platz 6 jetzt als relativ zementiert bezeichnen. Die haben für Aufsehen gesorgt durch unter anderem die Verpflichtung von Oberme Yang im Winter und durch den Spielertausch mit Meketarian. Arsene Wenger seit gefühlt – ja, Dekaden ist ja nicht mehr eine Untertreibung, er ist ja seit Dekaden schon da – allerdings auch schon seit dieser einen überragenden Saison die Invincibles nichts mehr gewonnen, nichts mehr Großes gewonnen. Wie ist die Situation beim FC Arsene?
Ja, genau so, wie du sie gerade beschrieben hast. Es fühlt sich so ein bisschen an, als ob da so ein kleiner Muff eingekehrt ist. Das Vertrauen, das Wenger über lange Zeit genossen hat, ist fast ausschließlich ausgeschöpft. So habe ich das Gefühl, also irgendwie sehnen sich alle danach, dass da was Neues passiert. Ich bin nicht sicher, ob sich da alles…
Aber jetzt ist ja was Neues passiert. Man spielt ja nicht im Achtelfinale gegen den FC Bayern.
Ja, leider. Zum ersten Mal in Wengers Geschichte. Keine Champions League.
Ich glaube, er würde dieses leider nicht teilen. Es war doch eher schmerzhaft für Arsene.
Da wäre ich in der Endabrechnung sehr gespannt, wie das bewertet werden würde. Denn eins ist jetzt klar. So wie es aktuell läuft, Liga-Pokalfinale verloren. Du hast in der Liga, brauchst du nicht mehr dran denken, irgendetwas zu holen. Also im aller, aller, idealsten Fall holst du Platz 4, was fast ausgeschlossen ist, weil da ein paar Mannschaften vor dir stehen. In der Endabrechnung sollten sie wirklich hingehen und die Europa League einfach in der eigenen Zielsetzung präferieren und wirklich alles darauf setzen. Dann wäre ich sehr gespannt, ob der Fan hinterher sagen würde, oh, immerhin die Europa League gewonnen, wir spielen jetzt Champions League, oder ob die sagen, nee, wir wären eigentlich lieber im Champions-League-Achtelfinale gewesen, weil das einfach mal mindestens unsere Zielsetzung ist. Da wäre ich sehr gespannt. Da würde ich auch gerne mit ein paar Arsenal-Fans drüber reden.
Arsenal Podcasts gibt es ja auch Deutschsprache, kann ich sehr empfehlen. Findet ihr alle unter rasenfunk.de. Wir haben jetzt viel Zeit verwendet auf die oberen sechs. Das war jetzt aber vielleicht auch für Ausgabe 1 dieses Blicks auf die Premier League mal notwendig. Was gibt es denn sonst für Überraschungsmannschaften, kuriose Dinge, die wir über die Premier League noch wissen sollten, Stand 28. Spieltag?
Also die Überraschungsmannschaften, da bleiben wir dann oben dran. Nämlich auf Platz 7 ist ohne jeden Zweifel der FC Burnley. Das ist unglaublich, was Sean Dijster einmal mehr hinbringt. Also die sind auf Platz 7 Vormannschaften wie Leicester, wie Everton, wie West Ham, wie selbst Southampton, die Geld ausgegeben haben.
Mit 22 geschossenen Toren nach 28 Spieltagen. Das riecht nach rassigen Spielen, die man da sehen kann beim FC Burnley.
Ja, es ist mega spannend, aber es ist wirklich mega spannend. Also ich habe die ein paar Mal übertragen in der Saison auch und es ist immer schön, weil du halt siehst, das sind fast durchweg limitierte Fußballspieler, die aber alle an das glauben, was der Trainer da draußen vorgibt und die einfach machen. Also Gehirn ab und dann einfach gegen den Ball arbeiten, ekelhaft sein und dann immer diese eine Szene nach vorne drin haben, wo sie eine Möglichkeit haben. Manchmal nehme ich genau 22 Mal vollenden sie, ansonsten lassen sie hinten einfach nichts zu. Das ist Wahnsinn. Dass die auf Platz 7 in dieser Geldliga Premier League spielen, ist eigentlich nicht zu erklären und ich versuche es dann immer in den Spielen, das zu erklären und es ist nicht zu erklären. Das ist Psychologie im Fußball, das ist manchmal, wenn es läuft, wenn du einen Lauf hast, wenn alle aneinander glauben, wenn alle an den Trainer glauben, wenn alle zusammen für etwas einstehen, lange als Gruppe zusammen sind, dann passiert manchmal sowas, auch wenn es eigentlich nicht erklärt ist.
Um das einzuordnen, der FC Bayern in den letzten 20 Jahren nur 4 Mal überhaupt in der Premier League gewesen, davon 2 Mal direkt wieder abgestiegen, in der letzten Saison Tabellenplatz 16 und jetzt 7. Also nur, damit alle Hörerinnen und Hörer das mal vor Augen haben, ist es wirklich etwas Grandioses. Kann man es ein bisschen vergleichen mit der Leicester-Meisterschaft?
Ja, doch kann man schon. Also ich glaube, Leicester hat etwas mehr Hotshotting betrieben in der Saison, will sagen. Die haben schon dann auf einmal Qualität dazu addiert, mit etwas mehr Geld im Rücken. Die haben ja ein Teilgremium, die schon auch ein bisschen rein investiert hatten. Unter anderem ja auch in den Trainer Ranieri rein investiert hatten, der viel, viel teurer ist als Jean Daisch. Und bei Burnley ist es so, dass da tatsächlich die Strukturen komplett gleich geblieben sind. Natürlich haben die auch Geld ausgegeben, also für Premier League-Verhältnisse wenig, aber für bundesliche Verhältnisse bleibt ja da teilweise das Hirn stehen, was die dann auch an Spielern dazu addiert haben. Also Chris Wood, Tor-Schützenkönig der zweiten Liga der abgelaufenen Saison. Aber insofern vergleichbar, als das in beiden Vereinen sehr, sehr stark infrastrukturell gearbeitet worden ist. Da gab es jemanden, der die Richtlinienkompetenz vorgegeben hat. Das war bei Burnley sehr stark Sean Dice. Bei Leicester waren es eher andere, die im Hintergrund gearbeitet haben, die viel in Scouting-Geschichten investiert hatten, die viel in Jugendarbeit investiert hatten, so in grundsätzliche Trainingsbedingungen investiert hatten. Und bei Burnley ist es halt sehr, sehr stark auf die erste Mannschaft zentriert. Aber ja, insofern kann man schon sagen, es ist fast vergleichbar.
Gibt es eine Mannschaft, einen Spieler, wo du sagst, über die haben wir jetzt noch nicht gesprochen, da sollte aber jeder mal, der bei DAZN in die Übertragung reinguckt, ein Auge drauf werfen. Neben Burnley und all den anderen.
Also ich glaube aus deutscher Sicht macht es immer Sinn, sich Huddersfield anzugucken, weil da einfach wahnsinnig viele ehemalige Bundesligisten mit dabei sind und weil das Team ja einen Liverpool-ähnlichearteten Spielstil an den Tag legt. Das heißt, es ist eigentlich immer was los, wenn die auf dem Platz stehen.
In beide Richtungen und sie haben halt die deutschen Trainer. Genau.
Genau, deutschen Trainer und eine halbe Bundesliga-Auswahl eigentlich immer auf dem Platz. Plus noch zwei, drei andere ganz aufregende Spieler. Ansonsten würde ich alles, was den Abstiegskampf dieser Saison betrifft, weil ich kann dir gar nichts sagen. Ich bin völlig ahnungslos, was da passieren wird. Die Mannschaften, wo ich mir ziemlich sicher war, dass die runtergehen – ich hätte Crystal Palace nach zehn Spieltagen attestiert – die haben keine Chance, die sind meilenweit davon entfernt. Da kommt dann Roy Hodgson plötzlich hin, der ehemalige englische Nationaltrainer, der jenseits der 70 ist. Die gewinnen zwar auch nicht, aber die verlieren auch nicht mehr oder ganz selten. Die stehen aber immer noch auf Platz 17, Punkt gleich mit dem 18. Swansea. Da sind sehr, sehr viele Enttäuschungen in der Saison im Moment unter dem Strich, nämlich Swansea, vor allen Dingen Stoke City und noch viel schlimmer West Brom. Also da bin ich besonders gespannt darauf, auf diesen Abstiegskampf, den wir ja auch bei der Saison immer schön covern. Also man kriegt ja alles bei uns. Deswegen, das macht mich noch mehr an als der Kampf da oben rum im Moment zumindest.
Ja gut, das ist ja auch eine ähnliche Situation. Vergleichbar zur Bundesliga, wir haben eine Mannschaft, die marschiert vorne weg und dann ist es die Frage, wie interessant findet man denn das Rennen um die Champions League und Europa League Plätze. Und der Abstiegskampf, da gebe ich dir recht, das ist echt interessant in der Premier League. Ja Uli, danke dir. Das war mal ein sehr interessanter Einblick rüber auf die Insel. Das war Uli Hebel von DAZN und danke, dass du mit dabei warst.
So gerne, vielen Dank.
Bei Twitter heißt er, at ulihebel. Ich fordere euch alle dazu auf. Ich bitte euch nicht, ich fordere euch auf, folgt ihm dort, denn es lohnt sich. Und ihr habt ja schon mitbekommen, die Spiele könnt ihr auf DAZN sehen. Das ist sehr praktisch, dass man das ganz gut serviert bekommt. Das war ein erster Kurzpass mal so zu einer Europäischen Liga. Lasst uns gerne Feedback da, wie ihr das so fandet und dann gucken wir mal, ob wir das vielleicht häufiger machen, hier im Rasenfunk. Zur Bundesliga gibt es ja weiter die Schlusskonferenz. Eine gute Zeit euch liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Macht's gut.